[Musik]
hallo hallo willkommen im bild buschfunk
heute anhalte wieder sarah
knappik vier staaten direkt mit unserem
ersten thema und natürlich geht es noch
einmal um janina josef jahre abgeschirmt
wie ein weltstar oder eben wie ein
schwerverbrecher uns haben die ersten
bilder vom flughafen erreicht hier sehen
wir janina josef jahren am flughafen von
holz brut auf dem weg zurück nach
deutschland zwei sicherheitsmänner
begleiten sie auf schritt und tritt
lassen niemanden an sie heran blick nach
unten gerichtet eine sonnenbrille
bedeckt ihre augen ja es hat für ein
beben gesorgt dieser haus wurf warum sie
rausgeworfen wurde das wollen wir uns
jetzt noch einmal ganz genau anschauen
gut auf seinen dreckigen und nun kommt
nur scheiße raus nur schokolade du bist
einfach
jetzt kapiert dass ich nicht diejenige
bin mit dem du dich anlegen wollten und
stell dir das sagen was
du bist nicht normal in empfang nahm
ach du bist sogar bitte jedoch im busch
wieder
kummer races das bild ja das
dschungelcamp wird zum krisen kern
gestern gab es eine sitzung mit rtl und
itv und was da besprochen wurde das weiß
unser kollege john puppen pokal ist für
uns in südafrika und wir sprechen jetzt
mit ihm über die große dschungel krise
john war
gestern zwischen aldi und rtl besprochen
worden
naja du merkst du ja der sturm zieht
heute erstmals über hits butt auf und
tatsächlich auch ein sturm mit einer
zelle aufgezogen nach dem großen
rassismus skandal das hat die
verantwortlichen dazu veranlasst eine
kurzfristige krisen sitzung einzuberufen
zwischen tv und rtl nach unseren
informationen natürlich das große thema
ist der rassismus skandal und janina
josef 4 an denn wir haben ja eigentlich
ist so verstanden dass rtl die
kandidatin rausgenommen hat reagiert hat
auf diese wirklich nicht zu
akzeptierende äußerung aber was ich nun
aus produktionskreisen erfahren habe ist
eigentlich ist so gewesen dass rtl auf
druck der kandidaten gehandelt hat und
zwar in der nacht nach diesen wirklich
skandalösen satz haben sich kandidaten
vereins sind im buschfunk an den sender
gewandt an die produktion und haben
gesagt dass sie das nicht hinnehmen
wollen und nicht hinnehmen können und
konsequenzen fordern und erst am morgen
nach diesem vorfall ist dann entschieden
wurden janina herauszunehmen mir hat es
ein
mitarbeiter erzählt dass man damit
natürlich eine art mobbing skandal
vermeiden wollen einen nachträglichen
mobbing skandal wie wir ihn vielleicht
damals vermisst unter palm
mitbekommen haben
wir haben weiter wird sie überhaupt noch
für rtl arbeiten kann
was ich jetzt erfahren habe ist das
tatsächlich erzählt die volle notbremse
ziehen möchte das bedeutet sie wird
offenbar nach aktuellen stand von der
abschiedsshow die ja nach der staffel
stattfindet ausgeschlossen und rtl will
ernsthaft die zwei tranchen die ich das
schon dessen thematisiert habe die
ersten anteile der gase die bei rund
60.000 euro liegen wird zurückfordern
kann für diese spannenden informationen
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt dass
junge kennt wird zum krisen kempf wir
sind gespannt wie es da weitergeht in
den nächsten tagen
auf druck der kandidaten sagte john
gerade john sagte die kandidatin selbst
sollen druck gemacht haben damit janina
aus dem camp geht und rtl war sich
eigentlich ganz so sicher ob sie
überhaupt raus soll man wollte
eigentlich irgendwie auch angefasst
hätten das damals selber mobbing im camp
abfahren von anderen kandidaten wir
haben auch dein rauswurf gefordert dann
bist du am ende freiwillig gegangen wie
war das damals für dich und hattest du
dir da vielleicht er auch konsequenzen
für die anderen gewünscht also was jetzt
aktuell bei dem thema passiert da hänge
ich nicht drin da weiß ich auch nicht ob
das stimmt oder nicht da kann ich nicht
zu sagen jetzt mit janina in diesem fall
bei mir hätte es eigentlich anders
laufen müssen da hätte man eigentlich
die kandidaten nämlich gemobbt haben
rausschmeißen müssen aber jetzt man kann
auch eine zeit nicht zurückdrehen es ist
jetzt so passiert wie es passiert ist
ich bin jetzt auch am punkt wo ich sage
ich bin eine erwachsene gestandene frau
und vergab auch den leuten für das was
passiert ist aber was man sich halt
wünscht ist dass man daraus lernt na
weil das gehört ja vorher im deutschen
fernsehen noch nie gegeben was mit mir
damals passiert ist ich war wirklich ein
junges mädchen das sieht man auch auf
den alten bildern von mir und dass man
daraus einfach lernen und du hast ja
auch krasse konsequenzen im nachhinein
gespürt ja also es gibt ja es gab ja
jetzt eine sendung die für furore sorgte
wo man auch gesehen hat dass eine kati
karrenbauer zum beispiel immer noch
nicht über die sache hinweg ist na also
ich finde nach so vielen jahren sollte
man thema auch endlich mal ruhen lassen
und sagen komm wir gucken alle nach
vorne und dann ist gut und dass man
daraus einfach lernt dass das nicht okay
es kein mensch hat das verdient
ausgegrenzt zu werden und beschimpft zu
werden und erniedrigt zu werden ich
finde sowas ist auch für mich kein keine
unterhaltung das ist eher bedrückend so
was wir haben jetzt aber so ein bisschen
die problematik ich weiß nicht wie es
dir geht wir gestern abend auch schon
geschrieben werden neben geguckt haben
man hat das gefühl
niemand will sich mehr mit linda anlegen
also das muss ich tatsächlich zu geben
das stimmt es ist natürlich jetzt nach
diesem
vorfall der passiert ist so dass keiner
sicht mehr traut ihr gegenüber etwas zu
sagen für mich ist mensch ist mensch und
es gibt entweder menschen die verhalten
sich korrekt oder es gibt menschen die
verhalten sich irgendwie nicht korrekt
und ich finde gestern diese frage von
philipp decher fußballspiel oder wie die
namen der fußballspieler sind finde ich
jetzt ist keine schlimme frage wenn man
sagt hey ich bin frankfurt fan dann
sollte man zumindest ein spieler kennen
weil mein papa ist zum beispiel aus oder
er sagt wenn ich sage ich bin für bochum
fern sagt er gesagt haben halt 23 namen
von lehrern oder ich muss kochen sein
und dann so auszuflippen also irgendwie
ich glaube die ist mit sich nicht so ein
bisschen im reinen irgendwie ich
finde ihre art auch nicht 100 prozent
und
dafür hat sich jetzt ein anderes
spielfeld eröffnet also jetzt habe ich
schon an na ja im moment es sind jetzt
nicht mehr linda und janina die sich
gegeneinander zocken mit der linken mit
linda legt sich jetzt keiner mehr an
dafür haben wir jetzt 90 krieg zwischen
jasmin herren ja ja ja hannuschka
ich nenne sie pen
kein mobbing war bills und um ein
bisschen frau ist sie doch schon aber
wir wollen es erstmal diesen schicken
alu ich habe also mal zu hause so schön
damit sie wissen worüber wir sprechen
die eisenbergs umzug den neuen zoff
zwischen anouschka renzi und
sagte was sagst du zwanzig mal etwas
amerikanischer statt ich mache das nicht
mit absicht ich mag es nicht um auch
eine zu ärgern ich hab mir
aber manchmal sei es aber nicht
michael nichts zu tun aber dass er
selbst stand ich ganz sicher ich bin
sehr sehr beständig glaubt mir
okay das ist ansichtssache
ok also also zahlen muss ich mir nicht
sagen lassen ich bin da nicht kurz vor
einer explosion besser aber
du möchtest das gerne mitkommen gut
rüber da hätten wir uns ordentlich habe
es an den kassen gab ich hab selber so
viel geschichte
ich jetzt alleine
drei tages
ja also die beiden sind sich auf jeden
fall nicht so ganz grün also ich sag mal
so man kann sich ja so einigermaßen auch
mal mit niveau streiten das sieht man
bei den beiden also es ist ja schon so
irgendwie so einigermaßen humanes
streiten oder sollte und unterhaltsam
ist nur auf dessen seite stehst du kurz
wirklich ganz ehrlich wenn ich finde
schon auch anuschka ist ein bisschen
faul gekrümmt kein finger jetzt kann man
von jasmin herren halten was man will
aber die packt wenigstens an mama kocht
ja das ist ja das was wir sehen also ich
kenne anuschka sehr gut persönlich wir
haben immer so ein ladies landschloss
der harald organisiert wo er dann
bekommst du gerne immer mit
ballett pendlern und das was ich schön
den iren und ich mag die anuschka
tatsächlich gerne die ist cool ich
glaube die wird verkannt kommt manchmal
ein bisschen unglücklich rüber aber wenn
man die kennt die ist sie die school ich
mag die und ich würde mir das auch nicht
von der jasmin gefallen lassen diese
lästereien und diese ganzen sachen also
irgendwie langsam verliert die jasmin
bei mir an sympathien und ich finde ja
gut wenn die wer sagt denn dass die
jasmin das machen sondern damit dann
würde ich es einfach sagen lassen
irgendeiner wird er dann schon machen
dann wenn sich verstört da mache es halt
ne wenig stilvoll böse sehr wenige bis
richtigkeit direkt drei jahren geht es
nicht hinter ihrem rücken das muss mir
beides hat ja erst mal hinterm rücken
geredet und dann hat sie sie
angesprochen aber nur in das finde ich
aber auch wieder gut man sollte nein man
sollte direkt menschen ansprechen will
jemand daran arbeiten aber die bringt
sich die jasmin bringt sich da selber
irgendwie in so eine opferrolle so die
sie muss es ja nicht machen dann sag ich
mach dir nichts findet er das opfer
musste aber was das letzte glied des
agri also dass wir keine anhand von ist
roger neill wir haben nämlich neue hütte
ein gast ist uns zugeschaltet uns was
der vater der sohn von willi herren denn
jasmin herren hat ja in den letzten
tagen schon ordentlich für zündstoff
gesorgt mit dingen die sie über ihren
verstorbenen ehemann gesagt hat und
jetzt wollen wir mit der fia sprechen
ich glaube es der fahrer findet an der
schraube ist
stefano
wir haben ihn wir haben in den letzten
tagen immer einiges an enthüllungen
gehört von jasmin herren bevor wir
darüber sprechen lass uns noch einmal
gemeinsam in die szene gucken denn sie
hat auch sie und die familie herren
wirklich schwer beschuldigt
wichtig also
ich glaube da haben sich an der wohnung
quasi festgehalten
und die vorhänge zugezogen und auf mich
eigentlich aber wild was warum was war
der hintergrund den hintergrund versteht
bis heute die freunde von billy gewesen
die familie von billigbier mutter starb
ganz wichtiges thema ich möchte einmal
ganz klar stellen familie ist ist ein
weiter begriff da gibt's ja mehrere
mitglieder es handelt sich nur um drei
familienmitglieder
was sagen sie zu diesen vorwürfen
also erst mal hallo zusammen und
was ich für die ganzen vorgangs und sage
erst mal finde ich es respektlos von
jasmin dass sie sich im tv hinsetzt und
die beiden menschen redet der sich nicht
mehr so wehr setzen kann
und fühle mich natürlich angesprochen
aus dem grund weil ich es nicht zulassen
kann dass mein vater seinen namen so
benutzt wird und deswegen fühlt sich
nicht dazu verantwortlich
zu dem ganzen zu äußern und
klarzustellen
also stimmen diese aussagen ist wirklich
von ihnen irgendwie angegriffen worden
[Musik]
findet man sowas wirklich dass es
wirklich völliger quatsch als würden wir
familie vor allem wer soll sie anfassen
meine tante meine tante anni ist aus
gesundheitlichen gründen kann sie auch
nicht mehr arbeiten und wer soll sie
denn angreifen das ist wirklich völliger
quatsch erzählt ich bin noch sehr sehr
schockiert darüber dass es solche
ausmaße nimmt das man sowas erzählt und
uns ins in irgendeinen licht rücken
möchte wo wir gar nicht hin möchten
ich bin schockiert darüber ich bin ganz
ehrlich das ist
kommt sie denn darauf warum erzählt sie
so was können sie sich das irgendwie
erklären
also ich kann es mir wirklich selber
nicht erklären wie diese gute freunde
darauf kommt dass solche gerüchte in die
welt zu setzen ich kann das beim besten
willen nicht verstehen
vor allem wir hatten alle ein sehr gutes
verhältnis zuerst gehabt
und das ist für mich sonst sehr sich
nicht her und müsste mich damit
auseinandersetzen
das ist für mich wirklich
sehr krass alles mein vater kann sich
nicht wehren und es werden solche
schweren vorwürfe hier uns vorgeworfen
als wären wir wirklich schläger die
erpresser dies und das l das ist nicht
mehr normal was für einer welt die ich
gegangen bin
ja das kann ich mir wirklich auch sehr
schwer vorstellen gerade wenn es um den
eigenen vater geht und wie sie gerade
sagten der sich dann nicht mehr wehren
kann ist eine versöhnung noch irgendwie
möglich zwischen ihnen und ihrer minen
oder hat sich da jetzt wirklich komplett
verbrannte erde hinterlassen also ich
will den ganz ehrlich von meiner seite
aus ich möchte wirklich nur meine
intention ist es irgendwie nicht hier
hass zu verbreiten oder in irgendeiner
art und weise jasmin fertig zu machen
oder irgendwas anderes spielt hier an
das ist meine letzte chance
ich reiche ihr die hand damit mein vater
und schnitt ihr wohnen kann und ist für
mich selber frieden befinden kann und
ich möchte dass das ganze ja wirklich
ein ende hat weil mein vater würde das
niemals wollen dass ihr kind da hier und
es mit solchen themen beschäftigen
müssen
erfahrene vielen vielen dank ich weiß
das kann ihnen nicht leicht gefallen
sein dafür vielen dank dass sie sich
hier eingeschaltet haben und darüber
gesprochen haben und ich wünsche ihnen
wirklich dass es zu einer versöhnung
kommt eben da mit spears' vater dann
auch in frieden ruhen kann vielen dank
für die vielen dank
kommen wir zu einem etwas schöneren
thema die müssen über die liebe sprecher
sagen die liebe schön ist es nicht so
immer schlimmer halt manchmal
schmerzlich und recht vor allen dingen
ist sie gerade auch nicht so schön
zwischen tara und philipp kann man
august von liebe reden weil der
natürliche verlor die sind die
verheiratet sind wie verheiratete wie
verheiratet dabei haben sie sich noch
nicht mal geküsst vielleicht sollten sie
erst mal knutschen um zu wissen ob sie
überhaupt zusammensein im euroraum
merken wir auch dass wir älter geworden
sind war es früher war das so dass nach
sieben jahren die ihr krise gekommen ist
heute hat man schon nach sieben tagen
die ihr klasse und hat schon alles durch
im endeffekt wochen kennt
ja das ist ganz furchtbar es gab große
tränen aus dem grund weil sie mehr
aufmerksamkeit von ihnen wollte der
typisches thema natürlich jemand eine
zeit war er muss das lagerfeuer machen
und und wieder psychologisch mit anderen
über die dramatischen erfahrungen des
lebens sprechen genauso wie die männer
halt sondern hertha tatsächlich zu ihr
gesagt ich brauche auch mal ein bisschen
halt für mich also ich kenne meinst du
dass ich hatte das auch schon mal
schafft können wir nicht mehr zeit
miteinander verbringen gut aber noch wie
viele autos so dass aber
vielleicht so nach vier jahre oder so
und wahrscheinlich erst mal zeit für
mich war wütend hören das ist natürlich
auch das thema was die twitter gemeinde
auf trab hält das ist einfach so schön
diesen ja diesen liebes liebesbrief zu
sehen nach einer woche beziehung bzw
nicht beziehung typisch sie will er will
milch sie liebt ihn sie liebt ihn nicht
ehrlich sehr liebt sie nicht ich weiß
nicht ich steig auch nicht mehr durch
die twitter-gemeinde die war wieder ganz
fleißig um wir haben
die besten tipps für sie zusammengefasst
fünf junge und es gibt wieder reichlich
zündstoff auf twitter unter dem hashtag
ibis ich bin ein star hagelt es nun so
viele kommentare die netzgemeinde stürzt
sich dieses mal besonders auf tara und
phillipe die es hinkriegen nach fünf
tagen schon eine echte beziehungskrise
zu haben nur ohne beziehung hier unsere
top heißt alle drei minuten verliebt
sich tara in phillipe lara ist feuer und
flamme für den sympathischen muskel boy
nur andersrum da hakt es noch ein
bisschen jetzt wird es böse eine userin
bezieht sich auf die netflix serie you
und unterstellt terra stalking absichten
tara nach dem dschungel ja die beziehung
von tara und verliebt ist kompliziert
ungefähr so wie diese rechnungen hier
ich bin mal wieder die sogenannte
liebesgeschichte von philipp und tara
gezeigt wird und sie wirklich netter
wird es auch nicht wir erinnern uns an
diesen eklat dora twittert phillipe
möchte nicht beim wäschewaschen
zuschauen tara das ist eine straftat und
zum schluss der blick der uns wohl allen
aus der seele spricht wenn beides wieder
tara drama läuft
vor das letzte bild ist so gruselig ich
hab das schon verdrängt wie lustig
manche leute schlafen im dschungel kommt
alles raus hast du auch ein bisschen
gesagt manchmal ja ein ich habe
geschlafen wie ein engel was denkst du
denn dann soll ich jetzt nicht
geschlagen
wie also twitter ist schon wirklich ins
winter ist's trade also ich habe
irgendwie bilder jetzt von mir gesehen
ich wurde auch jetzt vor kurzem
tatsächlich mit chemie firma zahn
verglichen oder wie heißt dann doch mal
die hier dieses aber ja aber nein aber
ja dieses von little britain oder wie
das heißt diese sind die autos sind die
englische cindy aus marzahn die
englische auswahl an rosen sagen hab ich
die englische cindy aus marzahn ich
finde es
wunderbar weil wir müssen aber noch über
lukas quartale sprechen für den ist das
dschungelcamp auch schon wieder vorbei
dann nicht mehr ins camp das wissen wir
jetzt auch schon seit einigen tagen
und ich kann ihnen diese zuschauer
verraten dass unsere reporterin kira ob
man ihn getroffen hat und sie wird auch
berichten darüber was rtl jetzt mit
lukas vorhat liebe kira durch lukas am
flughafen getroffen und natürlich will
ich als erstmal wissen ist er denn jetzt
eigentlich traurig oder ist er froh dass
er nach hause kam
lukas korte alles verlässt südafrika
hier mit einem weinenden und einem
lachenden auge das war ende natürlich
weil er einfach sehr sehr gern an dieser
show hätte teilnehmen wollen jetzt war
eigentlich der perfekte zeitpunkt er
wollte es schon im letzten jahr da das
aufgrund der korona krise ja nicht
funktioniert da gab es ja gar kein
richtiges dschungelcamp und ja mit einem
lachenden auge aber auch weil er jetzt
endlich wieder nach hause kann er hat
mir gestern direkt erzählt dass er sich
so darauf freut jetzt endlich seine
kleine tochter wieder in den arm zu
nehmen und jetzt die zeit auch erstmal
ein bisschen sacken zu lassen weil das
war natürlich auch für ihn eine
aufregende zeit er ist hierher gekommen
wollte an dieser riesig großen show
teilnehmen und kurz vorher kurz vorm
einzug konnte er nicht mehr weil er eben
diesen positiven pcr test hatte
gera ist denn das dschungelcamp für ihn
jetzt komplett vorbei oder sind alle
guten dinge drei und er geht flächen ein
ja das können wir tatsächlich jetzt
schon offiziell fast bestätigen bzw wir
nach exklusiven bildinformation eine
offizielle bestätigung gibt es dazu noch
nicht aber wir wissen schon ganz genau
er wird nächstes jahr ins dschungelcamp
einziehen und danach tatsächlich auch
bei let's dance mitmachen das hat rtl
tatsächlich jetzt schon mit ihm
vereinbart natürlich noch hinter
geschlossenen türen aber das können wir
tatsächlich jetzt schon exklusiv
berichten dass er daneben quasi beim
beim dritten mal seine chance endlich
nutzen kann hoffentlich danone corona
oder ohne weitere strapazen und darauf
wird er sich jetzt auch schon auf jeden
fall sehr sehr freuen tatsächlich wollte
er sogar dieses jahr gerne auch ins camp
einziehen obwohl er bzw nachdem er auch
seinen negativen test hier in südafrika
schon bekommen hat da hat dann aber
seine frau daniela katzenberger gesagt
nee macht das mal lieber nicht es gibt
im camp schon grüppchen und irgendwie
ist es auch blöd wenn man erst nach ein
paar tagen dann dazustößt macht es also
lieber im nächsten jahr wenn es dann die
möglichkeit dazu gibt und dass wir da
jetzt machen
danke dafür diese neuigkeiten ja
manchmal hatte so eine absage dann ja
auch was gutes also wenn er jetzt bei
let's dance mit also nach lancia im
wirklichen guten rat gegeben weil das
werk das wäre doch für ihn gelaufen wenn
er da rein gekommen wäre und an die
anderen haben schon die strapazen
von den letzten tagen hinter sich
gebracht ich finde das hat rtl gut
gelöst und ich möchte ihnen auch gerne
im dschungel sehen und balletttänzer
natürlich auch nadja
daniela würde ich auch gerne mal bei
letzten tagen jeder das ja eine gute
idee und und die sache sondern auch
direkt nur betreiben nämlich haben sie
auch noch nicht genau sagt knappik
bewirbt sich offiziell bei let's dance
rtl hier
nächstes jahr himbeeren dollar bereit
angela tritt gegen ihren eigenen man an
so was hat es ja auch noch nicht klar
das wäre auf die idee mir tut es
natürlich für lukas auch ein bisschen
leid total er wollte unbedingt in die
fußstapfen seines vaters treten
oder in die fußstapfen seiner schwägerin
oder in die fußstapfen von
danielas mutter ich komme jetzt
irgendwie ein bisschen durcheinander
weil irgendwie war gefühlt da schon
jeder von denen im kampf
[Musik]
liebsten hätte jungen familie und mit
der königin wollen wir jetzt sprechen
uns zugeschaltet ist ein wichtiger die
frankhauser herzlich willkommen im
forschung
[Gelächter]
die erste frage an dich lukas jetzt
leider nicht mehr da beiden schwer ist
das für den und kannst du auch seine
entscheidung verstehen
also es ist natürlich nicht ganz so
schön für ihn zumal er sich jetzt
wirklich ein jahr darauf vorbereitet und
darauf gefreut hat ich mein letztes jahr
wurde bekannt dass er rein zieht jetzt
hat es fast geklappt so kurz vorm ziel
und dann wieder nach hause also das muss
möglichst und dann nach hause aber zum
glück kann er nächstes jahr hoffen wir
mal mitmachen und dann hat er zwei jahre
auf diesen dschungel gewartet und ich
glaube dann wird da war mit extremer
motivation da rein
seine schwester soll da ja auch ein
bisschen eine entscheidende rolle
gespielt haben hat hat jeder so die
rosen bei den beiden
[Gelächter]
da man hat ja gesehen dass wenn sie das
sagt dann hört ja schon auf ihren rat
ich hätte mich natürlich gefreut wenn er
dieses jahr noch eingegangen wäre aber
ja klar ich mein wenn die möglichkeit
besteht das wusste ich nicht dass es
nächstes jahr auch noch geht dann auf
jeden fall nächstes jahr ich hatte nur
angst dass es vielleicht dann so ist
dass er nächstes jahr gar nicht mal
mitmachen darf quasi und deshalb habe
ich gesagt auf jeden fall noch rein aber
wenn nächstes jahr noch geht und
letztens allerhand auch alles richtig
gemacht da sieht man mal wieder alles
passiert oder fast alles passiert aus
einem grund
absolut richtig das ist für ihn
natürlich quasi ein jackpot du verfolgst
die aktuelle staffel natürlich auch ganz
ganz genau es sind jetzt wirklich schon
einige leute nicht mehr dabei aus den
unterschiedlichsten gründen
wer ist so für dich dein dein bisheriger
favorit wer sagt so kommt ganz ganz weit
nach vorne und warum
also ich bin auf jeden fall team harald
glööckler ich finde ihn klasse ich finde
er hat schon einige überzeugen können es
seien eingegangen hatte ein extremist
also alle hatten vorurteile über ihn
oder viele ich denke dass viele ihn ganz
anders eingeschätzt haben der ist total
ruhig er ist liebevoll kümmert sich um
seine mitkämpfer also ich finde wirklich
toll der pins mit um er macht jede
prüfung obwohl er vegetarier ist hat er
dieses gen ist gegessen der haut der
anderen lustigen spruch auswanderte
erste pläne ist also das ist was wo ich
finde selbstironie ich finde ihn klasse
ganz kurz der letzte frage von wem das
du ein bisschen enttäuscht
ich finde ein bisschen von linda ich
habe ehrlich gesagt gedacht dass die
sehr sympathisch ist beim ein spieler
und ich bin ein bisschen geschockt also
ich finde sie sehr provokant ich würde
dir aus dem weg gehen ich finde es
schade man weiß nicht was da echt ist
also ich glaube in echte sind total
liebe also kann es mir gut vorstellen
ich glaube immer an das gute vom
menschen aber was diese stadt wien so
ja wie sich da zeigt es ist schon übel
also ist ja sehr schlimm ehrlich gesagt
ja
ich bin auch ein bekennender harald
glöckler fan wir drücken ihm also beide
die daumen ich danke dir dass du dir
heute die zeit genommen haben und
vielleicht können wir uns ja nichts
sagen
sarah ja das ist schön in der hinsicht
sind wir uns einig ich wünsche es auch
vom herzen im harald und wie gesagt er
ist ein guter freund von mir und wir
werden das bestimmt beginn bekommt es so
auch zum ladies lunch mit kommst weil
das ist immer ein tolles treffen zum
ladies lounge zum vom ladies lunch zur
socke sarah knappik und ich habe mir das
teil eine völlig irre idee aber
eigentlich was ihre ideen nicht meine
idee ich habe nur mich bereit erklärt
mitzumachen und zwar wollte sie ihren
fußnagel versteigern für den guten zweck
für ein herz für kinder und hat mich
dennoch gebeten eine socke dazu zu geben
liebe sarah ich erzähle dir jetzt mal
war es okay es hat sich gestern ein
anonymer spender gemeldet ok und fand
die idee so lustig dass er gesagt hat
ich spende 1000 euro für ein herz für
kinder siehst du so und das war an der
sache ist du darfst ein fußnagel
behalten und ich meine socken danke
lieber spinner die ende gut alles gut
wir bedanken uns ganz ganz herzlich für
diese wundervolle spende von 1000 euro
für ein herz für kinder und ich bin so
erleichtert dass ich meine sache
behalten darf und ich ja hallo erstmal
erleichtert dass sie sich nicht von
ihrem zehn tage trennen muss wir sehen
uns morgen wieder im buschfunk und am
freitag da steigt hier die große
dschungelparty
20.15 einschalten und jetzt zurück zu
thomas und sander